now another town this week joined the
list of shame where sex gangs have
roamed seemingly unchecked to prey on
girls as young as 11 raping them
drugging beating trafficking and
potentially even murdering them in the
process what's happened in Telford could
be the worst case of a pedophile gang
involved in widespread child abuse
the country has ever seen but as I read
the names of those convicted something
struck me in Telford they included
Isaiah Ali Mahmoud mubarak ali and adel
Ali in a similar case in Rotherham Raz
one resid Adil Hussain and Zephyr and
Ramzan were among the guilty two
Rochdale now Mohammed Amin Abdul Aziz
and Mohammed Sajid among others were
convicted and now to Oxford where it was
an Jam Doga Kamiya Jamil and Zhi Shan
Ahmed ending up behind bars now a very
broad reckoning of the guilty shows
around 80% of men of Pakistani and
Bangladeshi origin well a couple of
observations then why do they appear to
view white girls as objects to be traded
and even disposed of and what is their
community doing about it look this is a
tragedy that's been going on up and down
the country and unfortunately the police
and local councils have been complicit
in covering up this scandal Wilson yeah
time and time again they have found that
British Pakistani and Bangladeshi South
Asian Muslim men like me have been
involved in grooming underage white
girls and targeting them in what I would
describe as racially motivated sexual
assault and for fear of racism the local
politicians for fear of losing votes and
the police for fear of being sacked by
those local local politicians have been
hiding this situation and of course then
it led to a national inquiry we know
that because the conclusions of a
national inquiry were the same I'm gonna
read to you something as Telford could
could well be worse than what happened
in rather than rather Roman Rochdale and
yet still despite that we have the
superintendent for Telford and Wrekin
Tom Harding saying the following you
said that some what I would say is
sexual offending across Telford and
Wrekin is virtually identical
proportionate to the breakdown of
society so it's not one particular
section over others forgive the language
the French but this is total BS because
it's confusing two types of sexual
offenses we as quinium looked into this
and I'm going to come to the stats and I
know you've done a lot of it and you've
done a lot of broadcasting you'll know
like in this area I have to say salute
what you've done thank you type 1 type 1
is the grooming of underage white girls
or any girl generates type 1 is a
category the grooming of underage girls
by gangs of men now in type 1 where is
that whether where the grooming gangs
are involved it was found in our
research that we found I'm gonna put
this up on the screen for you that 84%
of those involved in type 1 which is
gang grooming of underage girls were
what it says they're south-asian to be
specific they were Pakistani and
Bangladeshi Muslims right type 2 which
is hate to use the phrase ordinary
pedophilia what we normally understand
by the word pedophilia is representative
of wider society so one statistic found
it was about 87 percent in type 2 which
was pedophiles 87 percent were white
another found a hundred percent were
white but of course that's not
surprising because the vast majority of
the country is why what's interesting is
the disproportionate figure of 84
percent hailing from my background why
that's interesting is because roughly
only 2% of the country are Pakistani and
Bangladeshi Muslim men who are
responsible for eighty four percent of
collective grooming of underage white
girls your respect that I must get other
people involved a fantastic body of work
Carol I saw you nodding as I was
particularly sickens me on this is that
you know in all of these places that
you've mentioned the police the social
workers the care workers all knew what
was going on they couldn't pretend that
they didn't they've know this has been
going on since the 90s and yet they
chose because of what you're talking
about magic because the biggest crime is
to be accused of discrimination against
ethnic minorities they chose to throw
these young girls to the wolves and I
just I want to show you yeah I just want
to show you a bit of film here from the
MP of tell MP of 12 ins what has
happened in the past is it's not
clear:both to local authority or to the
police that what is being reported is a
crime and I think procedures have
improved I think practices are now
different but there are still young
people coming forward we feel that their
voices are not being heard you say that
to me is absolute nonsense because these
these girls have gone and made their
voices heard for decades and no one was
listed that is a really disingenuous
comment because these girls had nowhere
it's not just a case of somebody
grooming someone online some of these
girls as young as 11 were dragged into
filthy dirty houses and gamma-rays by
men they were perfectly aware that was a
crime compare and contrast with another
Labour MP in Rochdale or rather and made
the point and was promptly sacked from
bench talking maajid has we must get
others involved but he'll fit two of the
whistleblowers who tried to protect
these girls were fired all right Lucy
Alan the MP we just heard from she has
cooled for public enquiry and it seems
that there will now be one and it's
important say she has been cooling for
inquiry since 2016 so that anyone before
we were all talking about this she was
talking about the true scale of the
abuse and Telford but there's been it
and let's just hit this so I think
anybody with any decency is absolutely
appalled and horrified by these and
anybody who cares about children being
safe has to speak out about this and say
something is going wrong where we see
these patterns replicated up and down
the country and I agree with everything
that majid has said I think my concern
in the way we talk about this and I've
done a lot of work on this as a reporter
as Social Affairs editor before is that
there are two narratives that are both
equally dangerous right we hear that the
reason that the police and councils
failed these vulnerable girls is because
they were afraid of being accused of
racism whether that's true that is no
excuse there is no excuse for public
servants not doing their basic job of
protecting vulnerable children the other
narrative I've now heard from people who
work in child protection is that police
and local authorities now have this idea
in their head that people who abuse
children are Asian men of Muslim
backgrounds and that that is obscuring
the reality of other children who being
obese now that's equally dangerous
because if you care about children being
safe you want all children to be safe
you don't want prejudice in local
authority and police
keep putting children at unnecessary
risk but the thing I would say about
majid your figures but you know which I
remember at the time and it was really
important work when we talked about this
we talked about this being an Asian
problem a Muslim problem 100% according
to the nca of pedophiles
so not people who exploit vulnerability
but people who are just sexually
attracted to children or why we don't
and we also don't say that the white
community needs to work out what is
going about and why there is pedophilia
in its approach there clearly is no no I
don't think we are talking about type 2
pedophilia which is why who are
attracted to children of what we are
talking about is agen grooming you
understand that we need very briefly to
say this is a class problem this is a
cultural problem and this is also a
language problem also religion because
firstly on language these are pedophiles
who are raping children okay let's just
accept that and there these are not
women these not girls in relationships
with their abusers this is very cool
very damaging because there's no such
thing they mustn't call they mustn't
call the gut the girl victims
prostitutes they are rape victims of
rape they're dismissed in this case
culturally we have to understand why
this goes on in this country but finally
you see we haven't talked about class
and the reason why the authorities
turned a blind eye and threw these girls
under a bus or to the wolves was because
they were as it were in an underclass
they thought these girls are out of
Education they've been failed by social
services
honestly if these were middle class
girls at boarding school do you honestly
think these these children would not
have been taken in proper care of my
boarding school and you know my
authorities what I find astonishing is
that even after all of Rotherham
Rochdale ock said no prosecutions know
why this happens why and and if just
come to the final point of my
introduction decent Muslims like
yourself you're being tarred by the
brush even worse than anyone else what
what is to be done magic because it's
men like me they get stereotyped as
being rapists and that's happening
across Europe but unfortunately it's
happening because across Europe not just
Britain is a disproportionate rate of
offending by either Muslim migrants or
Muslims born and raised in Europe
against white girls and there are class
reasons to it there are patriarchal
reasons to it why it happens in
muslim-majority nations is largely due
to the social conservative attitudes in
society and their patriarchal and
misogynist attitudes towards women and
also cultural relevance kick in now for
example fundamentalist interpretations
of Islam believe that as long as you
have consent of the father there's no
underage there's no pre-puberty there's
no limit on marrying a girl they refer
to the Prophet having married a nine or
eleven year old depending on the age of
reference right these attitudes must be
challenged and they must be addressed
finally to Atlas point yes either 87
percent or 100 percent of the 100
percent of pedophiles in type 2 which is
those who prey on young vulnerable
children are white I have 87 percent to
100 percent but that's reflective of
society so it's a problem isn't magic
yeah but that's why I'm saying is
between that number because we have two
conflicting figures the problem needs to
be addressed but what it certainly isn't
is 2% of the society committing 84
percent of the crime that has to be
addressed as a category on its own now
the police haven't been doing enough nor
have the politicians yet this week alone
we find a journalist being stalked by
counterterrorism police at our borders
under Section 7 of the Terrorism Act
2000 being deprived of the rights of
silence because she was distributing
leaflets that were offensive to Muslims
that said Allah is gay that's not a
racist leaflet yet we've got this going
on in Telford
and I was I was ashamed at the lack of
response and the drag even in
organizations such as the BBC in
reporters yes I was a sheikh we have to
move on but I'm sure this will come up
again because it's such a terrible
problem